vice president mike pence destroys
senator kamala harris in the sole vice
presidential debate and we examine every
detail
the commission on public debate says the
second presidential debate will be
virtual and trump box and bill de blasio
gets even weirder than usual i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protection or online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben in fact you know what let me tell
you a little bit more about expressvpn
you want to protect that online privacy
don't you
don't you you should i mean there are
hackers who are looking out for your
data
it turns out that there's isps who are
using your data to monetize their own
services
many of those services designed to crack
down on conservatives so why should you
allow them
to control what you can see and what you
can hear and how your data gets
monetized instead
take back control of your data with
express vpn
see the problem with big tech companies
not only do they send for what you read
they actually track what you do online
they'll track what you're searching for
the videos you watch everything you
click
they use that data to serve you ads they
can match your activity to your offline
identity using your device's unique
ip address when i use expressvpn the
tech companies cannot even see my ip
address my identity is masked and
anonymized by a secure vpn server
if that sounds complicated it isn't with
one click quick download
you got this thing now on your computer
on your phone and now you click again
and it is protecting you full time so
why would you give tech companies a free
license to know everything about you
then turn around and sell off your data
time to take back your privacy at
expressvpn.com
ben i've been using expressvpn to
protect myself for years
you should too by visiting my special
link you get an extra three months of
express vpn service for free who doesn't
like to save money right again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn
ben expressvpn.com
to protect your data today okay so
last night was the big vice presidential
debate it may in fact be the last debate
as it turns out because
right now president trump is claiming
he's not going to do a second debate if
the second debate is virtual
and the commission on public debate is
now saying that
they want it to be virtual only
according to the associated press the
second debate between
trump and biden will take place
virtually amid the fallout from the
president's diagnosis of coveted 19
the nonpartisan commission on
presidential debates cited a need to
protect the health and safety of all
involved with the second presidential
debate the candidates will participate
from separate remote locations
while the participants and moderator
remain in miami that of course would
radically
shape the dynamic of the second debate
number one there's always a little bit
of delay when you're doing things
remotely there's very slight delay
generally
and that means it's very difficult for
trump to jump in if biden is lying
or for biden's defend off attacks from
trump it could turn into even more of a
mess you've ever been on a zoom call
with a delay you know exactly what i'm
talking about also
there are severe concerns and there
should be severe concerns about
what sort of information joe biden is
going to get remember when he's actually
in the room he can't be fed information
but his own people have routinely and
repeatedly refused to answer on camera
whether joe biden uses teleprompter
during interviews like whether they're
feeding him information during the
interviews by throwing it up on his
teleprompter you could easily see them
doing something like that
in the middle of the debate especially
because they've not actually disowned
that tactic
in the past trump says he's not going to
do it so trump said on fox business this
morning
he will not do a virtual debate here's
what it sounded like i heard that the
commission a little while ago changed
the debate style
and that's not acceptable to us i beat
him easily in the first debate
according to the polls that i've seen
but i beat him easily
i felt i beat him easily i think he felt
it too but i'm not going to do a virtual
debate
so you're not so mr president you're not
going to do it because the cpd
the commission on presidential debates
announcing this morning
that the second presidential debate will
be virtual are you saying you're not
going to participate
no i'm not going to waste my time on a
virtual debate that's not what debating
is all about you sit behind a computer
and do a debate it's ridiculous
and then they cut you off whenever they
want
now the commission on presidential
debate of course says that they have to
do this
for reasons of public safety of course
right now it is only october 8th
that the president will be free and
clear of this thing
by the time the next debate rolls around
presumably
it is unclear how long the virus is shed
but he will be immune if he continues to
recover
he apparently is symptom-free and has
been symptom-free for some 48 or 72
hours
at this point so it seems unlikely at
best that he's going to transmit the
virus
a week from now to somebody and it seems
like you could take some precautions
to the extent that you need to take
precautions in order to make sure that
they can have an in-person debate
you could do it in the open air you can
do it outdoors in the open air
12 feet apart from each other which
would pretty much ensure that nobody
is exposed to the president's covet and
again by that point
the covet should basically be done
nonetheless do i think trump will end up
debating i do i think trump will end up
debating because frankly he needs it
more than biden does if you look at the
polls right now he's trailing biden very
very heavily nationally and he's
trailing biden
more and more in the states there's a
new quinnipiac pull out today quinnipiac
is generally
somewhat favorable to biden but these
polls are devastating for trump they
haven't done 11
in florida which of course is an outlier
poll so far and 13 in pennsylvania also
an outlier poll
so far bottom line is this there has not
been a good poll for trump
in quite a long while in the various
swing
states in in the in pennsylvania the
real core politics poll average now puts
biden up seven points
in florida the real clear politics poll
average now puts it biden up nearly five
points
in wisconsin he's leading by 5.5 in
arizona he's still leading by about
three
and nationally he is leading by about
10. trump
in order to win this election really
needs to be within three to five points
of biden nationally he doesn't need to
win the popular vote but he does need to
be
in spitting distance of biden in the
popular votes that means that trump has
ground to make up
and if he's going to make up that ground
then he needs that debate so him walking
away from the debate
is very very unlikely i think okay with
that said if he does walk away from the
debate
that means that the last debate that
we'll probably see before the election
is the one that we saw
last night now in the lead-up to the
debate it was perfectly obvious what the
line was going to be
the new york times said openly in their
reporting that kamala harris was a
historic
wonderful human being because of course
she is black and she's a woman and this
means she's a historic wonderful human
being no matter what she does or what
she says
and that the only sort of attacks that
have come from the right are
crazed attacks that are racist and
sexist in nature calling her a radical
leftist well that already pre-set the
narrative that means that if you
criticize
kamala harris you're racist and you're
sexist and we knew going in that this
was the way this debate was going to be
played
literally 10 seconds after the debate
started i tweeted breaking cnn calls
debate for kamala harris and that's
exactly
what happened last night it turns out
that mike pence absolutely thoroughly
debunked
kamala harris i mean he dismantled her
it was truly a great debate performance
i've seen a lot of presidential and vice
presidential debates mike pence happens
to be very very good at this he is
smooth he only answers the questions he
wants to answer
and when he goes on attack he is very
meticulous in how he goes about those
attacks kamala harris by contrast
is wild there's a lot of smirking there
was some weird chuckling
she obviously wanted to goad pence into
somehow getting aggressive with her
he really didn't and so the media's line
which is that pence was too aggressive
that he was mansplaining to her
that all fell apart the reality is she
had nothing and what's even more
incredible
is that the attacks that she used
against trump
very few of them actually seem to stick
because number one we've heard it all
before
and number two a lot of that is drawn
from like bob woodward's book
and it's not from stuff that we have
seen from trump publicly per se
it doesn't mean that the public
perception of trump is really good it
means that pence did the best he could
with a bad situation namely covet and it
means that kamal harris is actually
really really incompetent
she's an incompetent debater i know the
legend of kamala harris is that she's
great at this because she once said a
mean thing to joe biden on stage but as
per her usual arrangement what she said
to joe biden there was factually
inaccurate
it was a complete it was a complete
misinterpretation of the fact
and then she had to back off of it there
was a lot of that last night with mike
pence
she she really did not land a blow
against pence and pence landed quite a
few blows
against biden and harris now is it going
to make a big difference it's a vice
presidential debate so theoretically it
could
because obviously we all know that
kamala harris is likely to be president
if biden is elected given the fact that
he is 78 years old and not in the
world's best health
but is it going to make a big difference
as long as
as long as trump is in central stage the
answer is probably not but this debate
is what the trump administration agenda
looks like without trump's crazy
seriously that's what this debate looked
like and you know what it looks pretty
damned good
you know for all the folks who say we
need trump's twitter we need it full
time we need
more trump ovation we need more trump
militancy let me just point out
that debate last night was fantastic the
debate was fantastic
because mike pence was the trump agenda
just as an agenda it was the trump
agenda without any of the ancillary
wild commentary and i understand maybe
you need the wild commentary in order to
draw attention
i understand that we all on the right
enjoy when trump punches at the media
and sometimes it is
well deserved as i've been saying for
literally five years at this point
donald trump is a hammer
i mean sometimes he gets a nail which is
great and satisfying and sometimes he
hits a baby which is significantly less
satisfying and significantly
less great but the point is this the
trump agenda
stripped of all the sort of trumpian
overtones
is actually excellent and when it is
defended properly as mike pence did
not like trump in the first debate as
mike pence did in the vice presidential
debate
that agenda is worthy of reelection that
agenda is worthy of another four years
it is pence did an excellent job laying
forth the trump administration agenda
laying forth all of the successes of the
trump administration
and they are plentiful and not only that
he contrasted
that agenda and the accomplishments of
the trump administration
with what kamala harris and joe biden
would do and kamala kamala harris had no
answers because the entire
biden-harris campaign is trump is an
orange man who is bad
that is the entire campaign she refused
to answer questions about abortion
policy
she refused to answer questions about
about
her coveted policy she refused to answer
questions on court packing she refused
to answer questions on foreign policy
kamala harris did not answer a single
question straight last night
not from the moderator and not from
pence and so she was relegated to
falling back on
he's being mean to me because i'm a girl
which by the way is playing directly
into sexist stereotypes
you gotta pick one if you're a member of
the media either women are the full
equal of men in the political sphere and
should be treated exactly the same
or women are delicate lilies of the
field who must be protected from the
gentle predations
of mike pence one of the most polite
people in american politics
if mike pence is too much for you in
american politics you need to get out of
the
you need to get out of the venue
entirely okay seriously
if mike pence is too harsh on you then
let me suggest
that that is a you problem okay that is
not a mike pence problem
if the media are relegated to talking
about how mike pence was mean to kamala
harris oh poor kamalaris
then don't give me that she's a tough
prosecuting lady she's
she is woman you're her roar these boots
are made for walking
don't give me that crap if the immediate
if the immediate
aftermath of a vice presidential debate
is why was he why was he mean to her why
did he sometimes interrupt her during a
debate it's called a debate
it's not discussion society we'll get to
all this in a second we're going to
break down the debate
it was an extraordinary performance by
pence like all credit to mike pence he
really did an excellent job last night
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about your safety and
security in your homes there's a lot of
reasons to be concerned about your
safety and security these days you've
seen crime rates rising
in your neighborhood or maybe you just
want to keep an eye on your kids
whatever it is you need ring i've got
ring devices on my home makes me feel a
lot more secure and again i can keep an
eye
on my crazy children who are running
around the house doing dangerous things
at all hours of the day whatever your
reason for needing ring you do need it
so go check out ring.com
right now you can get a special offer on
the ring welcome kid at ring.com
it comes the ring video doorbell 3 and
the chime pro is the perfect way to
start your ring experience plus free
two-day shipping you can see and speak
to whoever is at your door from anywhere
with video doorbells you can keep an eye
on every corner of your house with easy
to install indoor and outdoor cams you
can protect your whole home with ring
alarm
a powerful affordable whole home
security system you can easily install
yourself whatever you need for home
security ring.com can make it happen
for you head on over to ring.com that is
ring.com
get the special offer on the ring
welcome kit that's the ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro perfect way
to start the ring experience and free
two-day shipping
ring.com and go check them out right now
let's jump into the debate so the debate
leads off susan page
of usa today i thought she did a decent
job her questions were
some of them were good some of them were
bad i didn't think they were universally
good
she was tasked with something easier
than chris wallace wallace had to face
down the prospect of donald trump
completely just talking through joe
biden for 90 long minutes
and wallace lost control of the debate
then he lost control of himself in that
order
susan page really didn't have that
problem people on the left are mad at
susan page which shows you the pence
dominated
harris it just is a truism of politics
that if you're attacking
the referee then probably it's because
you didn't do great
now maybe the referee also sucks but
last night susan page did not talk she
was fine
susan page you know people were like why
didn't she hold them to the questions
why didn't she press them on the
questions you know these
these are professional politicians who
answer what they want to answer
and uh and paige basically you know she
she stepped out of it which was good she
didn't put herself at the center of the
story the same way that chris wallace
did
okay she started this thing off and she
made clear that she was not going to be
okay
with the sort of trumpian interruptions
that uh that happened in the last debate
we want a debate that is lively but
americans
also deserve a discussion that is civil
okay then uh then the debate actually
begins and as you'll see kamala harris
did not answer
a single question a single question and
she continually spewed lies
i mean she is a very dishonest human
being she's chameleonic in her own
politics
she's willing to literally say anything
i mean
i cannot ex i cannot emphasize too much
that kamala harris
is a person who literally implied that
the person who is now her running mate
was a sexual harasser
and a racist and now when she's asked
about it she says it was a debate
she said that to stephen colbert it was
a debate stan
i mean that was kamal harris so she's a
really really dishonest player
okay so last night the debate begins and
of course it starts with covid paige
asks kamal harris
would you impose new lockdowns in
masking and kamala harris just
completely ignores the question of
course
would you impose new lockdowns for
businesses in schools and hot spots
a federal mandate to wear masks the
american people have witnessed
what is the greatest failure of any
presidential administration in the
history of our country
and they knew what was happening and
they didn't tell
you the president said it was a hoax and
our plan is about
what we need to do around a national
strategy for contact tracing for testing
for administration of the vaccine and
making sure that it will be free for all
okay so a few things here one kamala
harris has a couple of modes
just in terms of modes so mike pence is
extremely stable in debate
you never really see him get upset you
never see him really get ruffled kamala
harris has two modes
faux sincerity and faux outrage that's
it those are the only two modes just
bounces between those
so faux sincerity is when she lowers her
voice and she starts to get a little
emotional i hate this in all politicians
right even politicians i personally like
ted cruz does this a lot that kind of
we're gonna go down here for the sincere
voice right whenever you go to sincere
voice no i'm
out but kamala harris does that a lot
she does the faux sincerity so there's
the
and that was a little girl like me joe
and then there's the faux outrage
i am speaking here i am speaking right
that
she bounces between those two positions
everything is fo sincerity and faux
outrage because she sucks at this she's
terrible
kamalaris is not good at this that's
what's so hilarious about
joe biden picking her from all of the
possible humans he picked her
and she's awful she's so bad she dropped
out of the primaries before
she was even put up for a vote in her
home state of california because she was
gonna win zero delegates
okay but even in that particular clip
she lies the president never said
coronavirus is a hoax that is a four
pinocchio claim according to the
washington post
does not matter and then she says that
her plan is a
national strategy on contact tracing and
testing and development of vaccine
mike pence answers he's like um so
basically that's our plan
and uh you are a kind of liar a little
bit
what i want the american people to know
that from the very
first day president donald trump has put
the health of america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
president donald trump did what no other
american president had ever done
and that was he suspended all travel
from china the second largest economy in
the world
now senator joe biden biden opposed that
decision
he said it was xenophobic and hysterical
the reality is when you look at the
biden plan
it reads an awful lot like what
president trump and i and our task force
have been doing every
step of the way and quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
that's a good line then you get kamala
harris laughing it off uh i don't know
if
i mean harris has to know she's on split
screen right so all of her reactions
last night were not particularly good
so point number one goes to goes to pens
right
he he says immediately your plan is the
same as our plan and then you pretend
that it's a plan it's not a plan
your entire plan is trump is an orange
man who is very bad and
harris knows immediately that she's in
trouble and she tries to bring out the
big guns
the big guns for kamal harris are not
all of the
trumpian policy mistakes or the terrible
things that trump has said over the
years or his bad tweets
the big gun for harris is i am woman
please please please leave me alone
right which is the most anti-feminist
thing you can say but she was waiting to
bring it out
she was waiting to bring it out and she
couldn't wait like 10 minutes seriously
within 10 minutes she's like looking for
an opportunity to
try to portray mike pence as some sort
of bizarre debate predator
kamala here's the deal you should be
treated exactly like anyone else on that
stage
mike pence did not treat you differently
because you're a woman
you are not mansplained to a man
explaining things is not
mansplaining a man debating you is not
mansplaining
and you proclaiming that you are being
victimized on the stage is a sign of
weakness it is not a sign
of female strength it is not we'll get
to that in one second first
let us talk about an unfortunate topic
right something people don't like to
talk about of course
we are talking here about erectile
dysfunction if you are worried about
erectile dysfunction it does affect like
half of american dudes over the course
of their life it's a medical problem you
should go get it solved right instead of
waiting around on it and just hoping
that it goes away why not just go
get the medication that you need go
check out roman right now they'll ship
you real medicine with free two-day
shipping the whole process is
straightforward simple and discreet
getting started is very simple just go
to getroman.com complete an online visit
ed used to be tough to talk about now
there is roman complete an online visit
today to connect with a doctor and get
it taken care of
very quickly just go to getroman.com ben
get up to 50 bucks
off your first month of ed treatment a
free online visit
free two-day shipping go to getroman.com
for up to 50 bucks off your first month
of ed treatment again that is
getroman.com ben if you've got a medical
condition
whatever it is there's no reason to wait
on it instead go get it solved right now
especially when you can do it quickly
and discreetly and easily from your own
home go to getroman.comben
right now once again that's getroman.com
get up to 50 bucks off your first month
of
ed treatment okay so here it is here was
kamala harris
you know playing the victim card here
she was claiming that mike pence
was mansplaining to her it's so terrible
he's interrupting here we go
the vice president said when asked well
why didn't you all tell anybody
he said because the president wanted
people to remain
calm well let's go i don't know but
susan i this is important
and i want to add mr vice president i'm
speaking i'm speaking okay now what's
amazing there
is that paige jumps in and interrupts
harris right she says
mr vice president because she wants him
to answer the charge and pence
then follows up on page saying okay
i'd like to answer that and she and she
immediately jumps to
i'm speaking here this is my floor i'm
speaking here
okay here's the deal that is called like
a normal debate and susan page was the
first person to interrupt kamala harris
in that tweet
in that particular clip the first time
she brings out and she kept bringing up
this gun throughout the debate
whenever she felt she was losing she
went to i'm trying to speak here i want
my time okay here's
after after all the time was was counted
up actually there are a couple different
estimates
at the very least she got equal time
with pence and by some counts she got
three minutes more than pens
but apparently she was victimized i mean
that clip is astonishing paige is the
one
who jumps in and then pen says okay now
it's my time no no i'm still speaking mr
vice president i am speaking here i am
speaking
you're gonna have to pick one again
women are fully
empowered it is wonderful that we have
female vp candidates they should be
treated just the same as everyone else
or women must be treated as though they
are
weak creatures incapable of handling a
a mild-mannered vice president saying to
them
i'd like to answer that please i mean
that's literally what my pen says
he says i'd like to respond like
i'm i'm sorry that and as we'll see this
became the media narrative it's really
really incredible
okay back to the debate so kamala harris
uh starts talking with mike pence uh
about uh about vaccines
and she's asked directly if she will
take a vaccine and she keeps trotting
out this nonsensical line about vaccines
where she says well if donald trump
tells me to take a vaccine i won't but
if doctors tell me to take a vaccine i
will what do you think donald trump is
down in the basement cooking up the
serum
you think donald trump is like taking
antibodies out of his own body and then
he's making a virus an antivirus
like will smith and i am legend like
that's how this is all going here at
kamal harris
or is it true that under the trump
administration operation warp speed is
developing a vaccine faster than any
vaccine has been developed in human
history
and that he deserves some credit for
that this is such a nonsensical and
silly line here's harris talking about
vaccines
you respect the american people when you
tell them the truth if the
public health professionals if dr fauci
if
the doctors tell us that we should take
it i'll be the first in line to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
okay i have a question does she actually
think that donald trump is going to be
out there
like okay you know this vaccine all my
doctors are rejecting go take it right
now
right now mike pence properly calls her
up well calls her out on this
and uh and kamal smirks throughout again
her performance last night was abysmal
the media are trying to save her from
herself they've been trying to do it
for literally years at this point when
she dropped out of the race we got a
bevy of articles
about what a wondrous wondrous candidate
she was if she was so wondrous
why was she so terrible here's kamalara
smirking as mike pence calls out the
point
which is that she is actively dissuading
people from taking a vaccine that we
will need people to take
the reality is that we're going to have
a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
we have five companies in phase three
clinical trials
and we're right now producing tens of
millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i just ask
you
stop playing politics with people's
lives
okay he is right about this and kamala
harris couldn't stop smirking throughout
okay when this goes back to al gore it's
not a sexist point
that people shouldn't smirk while
they're on split screens smirking and
shaking your head on split screens
looks bad kind of shaking your head
brutefully doesn't look bad in a split
screen
smirking looks terrible it looks smug
and it looks obnoxious
kamala harris was all of those things
last night okay then they got to the
issue of taxation so
recognize the first like third of the
debate was all about covet
and harris basically her line was that
trump knew
in late january early february this
thing was airborne and it was dangerous
even bob woodward who revealed that in
his book right that trump had said that
sort of stuff
even bob woodward said publicly
interviews we talked about it at the
time
he said i didn't believe that trump knew
all that i thought trump was just
bloviating
because again nobody knew that there was
not a single doctor including fauci who
was saying in early february the thing
was airborne and that it was really
dangerous for young people as it turns
out it is not particularly dangerous to
young people
and even now there is controversy about
just how airborne the virus is
right the cdc literally this week this
week came out with information
suggesting
there might be an airborne component to
this this week the cdc said this it is
now september it is not late january
okay so she relied a lot on bob
woodward's book for
various items of information but then
they moved beyond coven they got into
taxes and here
here is where the debate really started
to go sideways for harris to this point
you could say that harris sort of held
her own because on covet the fact is
that the
trump administration's rhetoric has been
bad and the trump administration's
performance has been pretty good
because pence is rhetorically much
better than trump especially this kind
of stuff
he made the record look as good as you
can make it when you have a president
who is doing all the things that
president trump is doing then they got
to the economy and this is where it all
starts to fall apart
for kamala harris so she starts talking
about she she starts talking
about the issue of the economy it's clip
eight
uh she says that there could not be a
more fundamental difference on the issue
of the economy
and in this particular segment of the
debate i mean this was a car crash this
was an
absolute car crash this was a smart car
against a big rig it just did not go
well for kamala harris here
here was harris trying to go off on
pence's economy
the depends trump economy the trump
defense economy and uh as you will see
pence just was not having it
on the issue of the economy i think
there couldn't be a more fundamental
difference between donald trump and joe
biden
joe biden believes you measured the
health and the strength of america's
economy
based on the health and the strength of
the american worker
and the american family on the other
hand you have donald trump
who measures the strength of the economy
based on how rich people are doing
on day one joe biden will repeal that
tax bill
he'll get rid of it okay and then
and then as you will see as you'll see
mike pence
just handed her hat to her and it's it's
really bad
so she says again again for the 90th
time
that the first day biden is going to
repeal trump's tax cuts
there's only one problem with that when
you say it's going to repeal the tax
cuts
as it turns out you're raising
everybody's taxes this is a point that
mike pence made with alacrity
harris tried to back off of it she
stepped right in it again because
they've been stepping in it all the time
but nobody's held them to account
we'll see mike pence do that in just one
second but first let's talk about the
importance of quality clothing so for
better or worse 2020 has kicked off the
work from home era
everyone is asking one big question what
exactly are you supposed to wear on that
zoom meeting
do you need to wear a tie well probably
not but sweatpants and your go-to gym
tea it doesn't feel right either what
you need is cuts
clothing it's the perfect solution to
your work from home wardrobe
confusion cuts is the best in the world
at making technical apparel for
the sport of business their t-shirts
pillows and hoodies have enough quality
and style to wear in the office on a
date anywhere in between
so you'll have to choose between a
classic look and a modern feel
after four years of development cuts has
finally released their new polos and
hoodies
the new pika polo was designed in los
angeles with
a custom engineered pika pro fabric that
keeps you fitted for the daily
work grind a happy hour escape
everything in between they've got new
hoodies that are made with their custom
hyperloop french terry fabric they were
designed with comfort in mind lasting
structure for the long haul this stuff
is durable
it is lovely to wear i mean really it
fits you exactly right
it is extraordinarily comfortable i only
wear cuts at this point all my t-shirts
are cuts cuts is loved by your favorite
athletes entrepreneurs even your
favorite podcast host seems like
everybody is wearing cuts to get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com shapiro that is
cutsclothing.com
shapiro for 15 off the only shirt worth
wearing
okay so kamala harris suggests that the
trump economy is bad
and that trump only cares about the
wealthy and pence just
just destroys her on it
despite what uh senator harris says the
average american family of four had
two thousand dollars in savings in taxes
the average household income for a
family of four increased by four
thousand dollars following president
trump's tax cuts
but america you just heard senator
harris tell you on day one
joe biden's gonna raise your taxes okay
and as you and then she starts smirking
and you get the kamala harris giggle uh
the weird strange joker giggly
okay and then she again she knows she's
caught every time she was caught last
night
she played the i'm a woman stop
interrupting me card all right she woman
explained to mike pence about how
debate is not supposed to be debate as
long as a woman is there
i do find by the way all this
mansplaining women are victims stuff
pretty amusing from a party that
suggests that men can be women
that gender is completely a social
construct and women do not exist in fact
men and women are arbitrary categories
decided by society rather than by
biology which means that i suppose that
kamala harris could mansplain to mike
pence anytime she pleases simply by
identifying as a man but in any case
here was kamala harris trying to walk
back the simple fact which is
if you repeal trump's tax cuts then you
end up repealing tax cuts
for 82 percent of americans who received
the tax cut
here was here was kamala harris trying
to walk it back and then pence tries to
interject and once again she does the
you're interrupting me you know stop
interrupting me here she was
joe biden has been very clear he will
not raise taxes on anybody who makes
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year appeal the trump tax cuts
mr vice president i'm speaking well i'm
speaking
be important if you said the truth joe
biden said twice in the debate last week
that he's going to repeal the trump tax
cuts that was tax cuts that gave the
average working family
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year that senator
that is absolutely not true that is he
only cutting
is he only going to repeal part of the
trump tax cuts if you don't mind letting
me finish
we can then have a conversation okay
please okay
again she like she gets caught out and
she has nowhere to go this is another
aspect of her performance last night she
kept basically saying i want my time
back i want my time let me answer and
then she'd get she
joe biden did this in debate too early
on he would do this routine where he's
like
i'm not finished yet i want to say my
piece and then everybody would stop
and be like
[Music]
yeah and that's what she did that's the
most part she's like i'd like to finish
her i'd like to finish and then he says
okay
let go and she's like uh but i was
basically like i mean can we all just
acknowledge that what i was really doing
here was just trying to call you a
sexist like can we really acknowledge
that
okay then pence continued to hammer home
this point i mean on the economy he just
he had her debtor rights on the economy
uh so he continued to hammer home this
point uh she was
saying again that that she was not going
to raise taxes that she and and biden
will not raise taxes on people which of
course is a lie
also she was saying that she's not gonna
ban fracking joe biden has said it
repeatedly that he looks to get rid of
fracking
she herself has said repeatedly that she
is looking to get rid of fracking
even the fact checkers who some who
somehow suggest
that the biden harris campaign is only
looking to get rid of new leases on
public land
are failing to recognize that all that
harris and biden have been saying the
whole time
is that that is a transitional plan
toward getting rid of fossil fuels
entirely i mean they've been very
consistent on this point
here was mike pence hammering this home
you're entitled to your own opinion but
you're not entitled to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the
eye and pointed and said i guarantee
i guarantee that we will abolish fossil
fuels
they have a two trillion dollar version
of the green new deal susan that your
newspaper usa today said
really wasn't that very different from
the original green new deal
is a prescription for economic decline
president trump and i will keep
america growing the v-shaped recovery
that's underway
right now will continue with four more
years of president donald trump
again kamala has looked terrible on the
split screen because she kept breaking
out the smirk
and the laughter that is every interview
she has ever done when she breaks that
out she's losing
and she was losing last night and losing
badly he kept also
hammering home on the green new deal so
so
paige who's in paige asked asked kamala
harris about joe biden and the green
deal this was
actually a very good question from susan
page the first time i've seen them
called on it
in which she says you know joe biden
deny that he's in favor of the green new
deal his website literally describes the
green new deal
so what's the deal here what's the deal
and then pence doubles down on it harris
i gotta say i'm not sure which was more
stunning how well pence performed or how
badly harris performed
i think probably the latter because
expectations for harris were much higher
than expectations for pence
but uh she it was a mismatch last night
it was
this was this was a heavyweight with a
lightweight it was that simple
she has knowledge of issues that goes
about half an inch deep and it does not
go a mile wide
here was susan page unintentionally
finishing kamal harris on the green new
deal
vice president biden said in last week's
debate that he does not support the
green new deal
but if you look at the biden harris
campaign website it describes the
greener deal
as a crucial framework joe believes
again in science
we have seen a pattern with this
administration which is they don't
believe in science
and joe's plan is about saying we're
going to deal with it but we're also
going to create jobs
you were the first senate co-sponsor of
the green new deal
and while joe biden denied the green new
deal susan thank you for pointing out
the green new deal is on their campaign
website okay there's a reason
that pence kept hammering home on the
green new deal the green new deal is a
debacle
it is spending by aoc's plan some 93
trillion dollars over 10 years
okay so he he hammered the green new
deal i think he mentioned the green news
deal 15 times
last night and correctly so so another
issue on which pence just excoriated her
then
they got to the issue of china so both
candidates were asked about china
kamala harris had no answer other than
to say and she really said this she said
that xi jinping was more popular
internationally than donald trump okay
first of all
the image of china around the world has
been in steady decline as it should be
because it's a tyrannical hellhole
i mean in terms of how it is run the the
the
tyrant xi jinping has been subjecting a
million weaker muslims
to concentration camps he has been
you know basically welding people in
their houses in wuhan
he he cares nothing about his citizenry
he's a dictator he's a dictator tamil
harris defended the dictator
at one point she suggested that trump
had lost the trade war with china
and pence had a great rebuttal to this
the vice president earlier referred to
as part of
what he thinks is an accomplishment um
the the president's
trade war with china you lost that trade
war
you lost it lost the trade war with
china joe biden never fought it
yeah and he correctly kept pointing out
that the biden
campaign the the biden administration
was very very soft on china how do you
know by the way that biden
that pence is right we could fact-check
this in real time as it turns out
it turns out that the debate was
broadcast on chinese television
every time pence talked about china and
the predations of china and the
corruption of china
and how china was responsible for the
spread of coronavirus china blocked the
feed
really this this is true every time
kamala harris talked about china
the feed came back on doesn't that say
something about how the chinese
government views the two candidates
when pence talks about the predations of
china china blocks the feed
when kamala harris talks about china
they're like
slow clap okay if china views you that
way it's a good is a good indicator
those people should not be
in power okay in just a second we're
going to go to trade and we're going to
go to
the the personal liberalism of kamala
harris and foreign policy i mean
on foreign policy again the trump
administration without the
without the trumpian affect is excellent
very very good if you like what you saw
last night for mike pence then what you
should want is more of that
right not more distraction not more
mind-melting tweets
not more of that okay if if donald trump
used his twitter sparingly
and if he used it in targeted fashion
i'd be a huge fan
what we saw last night is what what it
looks like when the trump administration
policy is explicated outside of twitter
and it looked pretty damned good it
looked pretty damned good which is why
the media today are talking about
nothing but a fly landing on mike
pence's head
and maybe his pink eye and kamala harris
being the victim of sexism those are the
three themes of the media which means
cleaner last night we're gonna get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact you're
spending an awful lot of time these days
in front of screens i mean half of us
are working virtually
i mean you're spending a lot of time in
front of a computer that can give you
headaches it can keep you up
at night what you need is some great
blue light filtering technology and i
have the answer
for you i am talking of course about
felix gray glasses
many blue light glasses don't filter
enough blue light especially in the
range that matters
there are a lot of blue light glasses on
the market they're not all created equal
well
felix gray glasses they filter out 90 of
blue light in the most damaging range
and eliminate 99
of glare through a proprietary
industry-leading lens technology only
available with felix gray you can order
online
glasses will ship directly to you with a
hard case and lens cloth included
trim for 30 days risk free if your
screens aren't easier on the eyes then
send them back
for a full refund i love my felix spray
glasses they look great they are
extremely
durable and they minimize the chance of
headaches go to felix
for the absolute best grayglasses.com
blue light filtering glasses on the
market again that's felix
gray glasses dot com slash ben f-e-l-i-x
g-r-a-y glasses dot com
slash ben shipping and returns totally
free at felix gray felix grayglasses.com
ben okay so we're gonna get some more of
this debate
in just one second first you're going to
need to be a subscriber over at
dailywire.com
if you truly enjoyed matt walsh breaking
down that vice presidential debate in
real time well why the hell wouldn't you
be a subscriber
over at dailywire.com we have all sorts
of goodies coming up for you next week
i'll be doing all access we do an all
access with one of our hosts
every single night if you like all this
stuff you should join daily wire right
now as an insider or all access member
get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all of our upcoming debate coverage
live at dailywire.com apple tv or the
roku app also our members get our
articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show exclusive
readers past content available only to
daily wire members if you're considering
an all-access membership you get to join
us on all access live again every night
for online and live stream discussions
you get not one but two leftist years
tumblers with your membership as well as
early sometimes exclusive access
to new fantastic daily wire products so
watch the next debate with us get 20
off your daily wire membership with code
debate when you sign
up today you are listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so moving from domestic policy to
foreign policy the story didn't get any
better
for kamala harris uh she talked about
foreign policy
and everything she says here is just
ridiculous like patently ridiculous on
his face
here was kamala harris being absurd just
absurd
the the biden foreign policy case is
that biden has been wrong on every major
foreign policy issue of the last 30
years
seriously it is it is difficult to
imagine anyone who has ever been more
wrong on foreign policy
this is a guy who did not want to kill
osama bin laden there's a guy who's very
much in favor of the iran deal this is a
person who's
great suggestion repeatedly is that
whenever there's a problem we should
just split countries apart
and heroes kamala harris though trying
to pretend that joe biden is some sort
of foreign policy genius
when in fact the guy is as much of a g
he's the ralph wiggum of foreign policy
here's kamala harris trying to spin
ralph wiggum into mr burns
i love talking with joe about a lot of
these issues and you know joe
he i think he said it quite well he says
you know foreign policy
might sound complicated but really it's
relationships so just think about it as
relationships
and so we know this in our personal and
professional relationships
um you gotta keep your word to your
friends
gotta be loyal to your friends people
who've stood with you gotta stand with
them
you gotta know who your adversaries are
and keep them in check
but what we have seen with donald trump
is that he has betrayed our friends
and it and and and and and embraced
dictators around the world we were in
the iran nuclear deal with friends with
allies around the country
okay the um the what so there are a few
things here that are hilarious one
he says we're in the iran nuclear deal
with friends and with allies around the
country okay number one
you may have had some europeans uh and
on that deal you're also in the deal
with the iranians with the iranian
mullahs who are not your friends they
are terrorists
and when she says you got to keep your
word to your friends the obama biden
administration was the most anti-israel
administration in american history
they literally tried to withdraw defense
equipment from israel in the middle of a
war with hamas
they were awful they they betrayed
eastern european allies
in the face of russian predation the the
obama biden foreign policy was a
full-scale disaster on every virtu
like virtually every level and this is
something that mike pence then proceeded
to
point out and it did not i mean this
this foreign policy section debate went
really
really poorly for kamala harris here's
mike pence
president trump kept his word when we
moved the american embassy to jerusalem
we stood strong with our allies but
we've been demanding
nato is now contributing more to our
common defense than
ever before thanks to president trump's
leadership
we've strengthened our alliances across
the asia pacific
president trump unleashed the american
military
and our armed forces destroyed the isis
caliphate
and took down their leader al-baghdadi
without one american casualty
the last administration transferred 1.8
billion dollars
to the leading state sponsor thank you
very much of terrorism
president donald trump got us out of the
day thank you vice president and
and when constant solomonie was
traveling to baghdad
thank you vice president okay and of
course this is exactly right okay the
fact is that the trump foreign policy
agenda is so much better i mean it is
the highlight it really is it's one of
the highlights
of the of the trump administration and
then pence really
hit kamal harris where it hurts and he
pointed out
that the the obama administration
allowed the rise of isis
and he points to the story of kayla
mueller who's taken prisoner
by the by the isis terrorists and then
murdered
and her family saying quite openly that
if donald trump had been president that
never would have happened
when joe biden was vice president we had
an opportunity
to save kayla miller breaks my heart to
reflect on them but the military came
into the oval office
presented a plan they said they knew
where caleb was
baghdadi had held her for 18 months
abused her mercilessly before they
killed her but when joe biden was vice
president
they hesitated for a month and when
armed forces finally went in
it was clear she'd been moved two days
earlier and her family
says with a heart that broke the heart
of every american that
if president donald trump had been
president they believe kayla would be
alive today
okay harris had no comeback for that she
said oh well condolences to caleb
muller's family that's pretty much it
that's pretty much it so harris's
response to all of this is that donald
trump is personally mean to the military
she relied very heavily on an atlantic
story that has been
debunked by 14 different sources there
are a bunch of people who know trump
he did not say of people at arlington
national cemetery that they were suckers
and losers right all of this
is is from an atlantic story that was
unsourced right it was a bunch of
unverified sources unnamed sources okay
and then there were people like john
bolton who are no friends of trump who
said no he never said anything he didn't
cancel a visit
to a grave site in in europe
because of his dislike for fallen
soldiers or anything it was raining
outside
and and provided some some actual
problems for security
that was her line right her line is
trump is mean to the military of course
she complete and then she did this weird
thing
where she somehow disagreed with the
killing of kasem solomoni which was very
odd so here was kamala harris yeah again
most of most of her attack lines last
night were from two things the bob
woodward book
and the atlantic story that's pretty
much what she had
this is about a pattern of donald
trump's where he has referred
to our men who were serving in our
military as
suckers and losers donald trump
who went to arlington cemetery
and stood above the graves
of our fallen heroes
and said what's in it for them
because of course you know he only
thinks about what's in it
for him let's take what he said about
john mccain
a great american hero public reporting
that russia had bounties on the heads
of american soldiers okay there are a
few things here one
i i i'm not gonna hear about criticisms
of john mccain from democrats who
literally suggested that he was a racist
back in 2008
and also that he was a decrepit person
who couldn't use a keyboard
and when he had war injuries also that
public reporting about russian bounties
is completely unverified in fact that
story
basically fell apart pence then knocked
the the biden harris campaign on the
fact that joe biden
you know was against the killing of
osama bin laden trump made the call to
kill solomon a correct call and biden
held up when it came time to kill osama
bin laden
qasim salamani the iranian general was
responsible for the death of
hundreds of american service members
when the opportunity came we saw him
headed to baghdad to
kill more americans president trump
didn't hesitate
and qasim salamani is gone but you
deserve to know that joe biden
and kamala harris actually criticized
the decision to take out solomon
qasim salamani it's really inexplicable
but
with regard to joe biden it's it's
explainable
because history records that joe biden
actually opposed the raid against osama
bin laden
i have a question what is she shaking
her head at there's not a she literally
one second before said it was bad to
kill solimani what's she shaking her
head at okay then they moved to the
supreme court
and on the supreme court once again it
was a it was it was
a giant fail for kamalaris so pence
began
by pointing out that it was kamal harris
who savaged justice kavanaugh
and was brutal and vicious and lying
about justice kavanaugh and he said i
hope that you don't treat
amy coney barrett with the same sort of
disdain especially people like
you who have been ripping on people for
their religion because you have actually
ripped on
federal judicial appointees who are
members of things like the knights of
columbus calling them bigoted
groups here was pence going after harris
president trump and i could not be more
enthusiastic
about the opportunity to see judge amy
coney barrett become justice amy coney
barrett
she's a brilliant woman and she will
bring a lifetime of experience and
a sizable american family to the supreme
court of the united states
and our hope is in the hearing next week
unlike justice kavanaugh received with
treatment from you and others
but we hope she gets a fair hearing and
we particularly hope that we don't see
the kind of attacks
on her christian faith that we saw
before
senator i know one of our judicial
nominees you actually
attacked because they were a member of
the catholic knights of columbus
okay what's hilarious about this is that
her response was
i'm a person of faith how dare you
suggest that i would attack a person of
faith
you literally attack somebody for being
a member of the knights of columbus this
does not hold water here from kamala
harris
joe biden and i are both people of faith
and it's insulting to suggest that we
would
knock anyone for their faith on the
issue of this
of this nomination joe and i are very
clear as are the majority of the
american people
we are 27 days before the decision about
who will
be the next president of the united
states and you know before
when this conversation has come up you
know it's been about election year or
election time
we're literally in an election there's
the issue of choice
and i will always fight for a woman's
right to make a decision about her
own body this is my favorite thing i
would never attack anybody for their
religion but also there should be
taxpayer
taxpayer-funded abortion and religious
institutions should be forced to cover
insurance that covers abortion
so yes yeah i'm sure that your your
religious qualms
would never prevent you from from doing
anything like that uh kamala harris
okay but when it came to court packing
this is really where it got ugly so
she once again refused to answer whether
she should pack the court and pence
really pushed her on it
and she refused and she refused and she
refused i mean
over and over and over again she kept
saying we're voting we're voting we'll
vote yes we know we're voting we should
know what we are voting for
it makes a difference whether you and
joe biden are going to change the number
of people
on the supreme court out of a pure
revenge move because you don't like the
fact that ruth bader ginsburg died and
trump was in office
so pence pushed her on this and finally
he got a response from her
she had no response and she really
didn't and so finally she went to her d
her default responses her default
responses throughout this debate
were you're a sexist you're a sexist
stop interrupting me you're a sexist and
then finally she went to her big gun
right you were waiting for her to go
that was the little gun that was the
derringer then she finally went to the
shotgun the shotgun was
racist right that's her she you knew she
was going here and she finally got there
how did she get there in the most
bizarre possible fashion so she was like
are we gonna pack the court
are we gonna pack the court you're not
appointing enough black justices
okay i have a question i have a question
you like clarence thomas do you
really how about if we appointed like
miguel estrada
you know more people of color because it
seems like you treat black republicans
really well over there kamala it seems
like you would care deeply
if we appointed a bunch of textualists
and originalists to the bench and if
they were black you'd be fine with that
or alternatively you're just a damned
liar so here she was last night she
wouldn't answer on court packing but in
the end
it's mike pence's fault because the the
judges who are being appointed are not
black enough or some such
bull crap you once again gave a
non-answer joe biden gave it anonymous
trying to answer you american people
deserve a straight answer
and if you haven't figured it out yet
the straight answer is they are going to
pack the supreme court
if they somehow win this election men
and women
i got to tell you people across this
country if you cherish our supreme court
if you cherish the separation of powers
you need to reject
the biden harris ticket yeah let's talk
about pack in the court then
let's talk about the fact yeah i'm about
to do you know
that of the 50 people who
president trump appointed to the court
of appeals for lifetime appointments
not one is black i just want the record
to reflect she never answered the
question
[Laughter]
no i'm about to i'm about to answer the
question i'm about to also you're a
racist
man good answering the question there
kamala and the media just let her get
away with the scrap they just
let her get away with this crap okay the
debate
moved on to other topics so some of the
hotly fraught topics
that came up in the debate last night
one was the issue of race so
the moderator brought up the case of
briana taylor and said was brianna
taylor's you know the acquittal of the
officers was that justified
and kamala harris great legal mind she
said no no
it was it was it was not justified it
was not justified
and then she talked i i couldn't believe
this she actually talked about
you know she talked about george floyd
and she see the number of lies in this
particular clip is extraordinary
i mean it's almost infinite it's like
packing all of the dense matter of the
universe into a single point before the
big bang except
all of the matter is lies and the single
point is this clip here's kamala harris
saying a bunch of untrue things in a row
her life was taken unjustifiably and
tragically and violently
and it just it brings me to
you know the eight minutes and 46
seconds that america
witnessed during which
an american man was tortured
and killed under the knee
of an armed uniformed police officer
and people around our country of
every race of every age of
every gender perfect strangers to each
other
marched shoulder to shoulder arm and arm
fighting for us to finally achieve
that ideal of equal justice under law
and i was a part of those
peaceful protests we need reform of
our policing in america and our criminal
justice system which is why joe and i
will immediately ban chokeholds and
carotid holes
he said that george floyd would be alive
if that legislation had passed okay
there's only one problem george played
in all likelihood would not be alive
that legislation had passed because he
was not put in either carotid
or a chokehold and he died because he
was on a dose of fentanyl that would
kill a horse the autopsy found that he
had fentanyl and meth in his system
he was obviously experiencing excited
delirium in the middle of that encounter
when it comes to brianna taylor it is
tragic that she was killed
she was killed because her boyfriend was
firing a gun at the cops when they broke
in the door
in a legally performed search warrant
and
it is amazing to me that the democrats
will simultaneously claim that outdoor
open air events at the white house are
very very very bad and very very
dangerous okay fine
and you don't get to talk about how you
were marching shoulder to shoulder in
the middle of a pandemic
with millions of other people in a fight
for quote-unquote racial justice and
completely overlooked the violence in
the streets here's mike pence pointing
out many of these things
it really is remarkable that as a former
prosecutor
you would assume that an impaneled grand
jury looking at all the
evidence got it wrong but you're
entitled to your opinion
senator i think
and with regard to george floyd there's
no excuse for what happened to george
floyd
and justice will be served but there's
also no excuse for the rioting
and looting that followed
i mean it really is astonishing flora
westbrook is with us here tonight in
salt lake city
just a few weeks ago i stood at what
used to be
her salon was burned to the ground
by rioters and looters and and flora is
still trying to put her life back
together
and i must tell you this this this
presumption
that you hear consistently from joe
biden and kamala harris
that uh that america is systemically
racist
and that as joe biden said that he
believes that law enforcement has an
implicit
bias against minorities
is is a great insult
to the men and women who serve in law
enforcement and i want everyone to know
who puts on the uniform of law
enforcement every day
and president trump and i stand with you
and it is remarkable that that when
senator tim scott
tried to pass a police reform bill
brought together a group of republicans
and democrats senator harris
you got up and walked out of the room
and then you filibustered senator
tim scott's bill okay and that prompted
her
to bring up the great trump loves white
supremacist lie
again so this was the pattern last night
everybody's a sexist for being mean to
me
and then everybody's a racist for being
mean to me so harris immediately went to
well trump was never he he didn't
condemn white supremacists
and good for mike pence mike pence
actually debunked this now here is the
point at which the media starts to go
nuts why well because kamala harris is
losing
and as you will see there is a fly that
lands on mike pence's head ooh a fly
well i guess that we all have to go
crazy over the fly guys there's a fly on
mike pence's head
this is how stupid our politics are our
political analysts last night
did not want to talk about the actual
content of the debate because kamala
harris did terribly
instead what they really really wanted
more than anything else in the world was
to talk about this dumb fly
on mike pence's head so here is kamala
harris suggesting that trump won't
condemn white supremacists and then
we'll get to mike pence completely
rebutting this and going after the media
in the pro
this performance by pence was excellent
it was very very good here was harris
and trotting out the trump loves white
supremacist lie
i will not sit here and be lectured by
the vice president
on what it means to enforce the laws of
our country i am the only one on this
stage
who has personally prosecuted everything
from child
sexual assault to homicide the president
of the united states took a debate
stage in front of 70 million americans
and refused to condemn
white supremacists he called mexicans
rapists and criminals he instituted as
his first act a muslim ban
he on the issue of charlottesville where
people were
peacefully protesting the need for
racial justice
where a young woman was killed and on
the other side there were neo-nazis
carrying
tiki torches shouting racial epithets
anti-semitic slurs
and donald trump when asked about it
said
there were fine people on both sides
okay here is mike pence
completely debunking this ridiculous
talking point at his ridiculous talking
point also
listening to kamala harrison the
democratic party talk about anti-semitic
slurs while they
maintain rashida talib and ilhan omar
and they continue to promote
these these anti-semitic dollars is
pretty impressive here's pence going
after harris
you know i think that's one of the
things that makes people dislike the
media so much in this country susan
is that you selectively edit just like
senator harris did
comments that president trump and i and
others on our side of the aisle
i mean senator harris conveniently
admitted after after the president made
comments about people
on either side of the debate over
monuments
he condemned the kkk neo-nazis and white
supremacists and has done
so repeatedly you're
concerned that he doesn't condemn
neo-nazis
president trump has jewish grandchildren
i'm glad you brought up your record
senator thank you
that's i really need to make this point
when you were when you were d.a
in san francisco when you left office
african-americans were 19 times more
likely to be prosecuted for minor drug
offenses than whites and hispanics when
you were attorney general of california
you increased the report the
disproportionate incarceration of blacks
in california
you did nothing on criminal justice
reform in california
you didn't lift a finger to pass the
first step back on capitol hill
i mean the reality is your record speaks
for itself
i mean she's caught out you can tell her
starting to chuckle there that's the
chelsea gabbard attack she still has not
found an answer
to the tulsi gabbard attack so pence
stellar performance kamal harris really
really truly terrible performance now
how do you know for a fact
that it was a truly terrible performance
by kamal harris you can tell by the
media coverage
so the media coverage was completely
about how kamala harris was the victim
of a racist attack so cnn did a
post-debate snap poll
where it said that six in 10 said harris
won 38 said
mike pence had a better not a knight
well going in
61 said they thought harris would win
and 36 thought pence would win so
basically nobody changed their mind
big shocker there because everybody is
is really sort of
ensconced in their particular corner
which just shows how much this
this whole campaign has been dominated
by the personality of president trump
but you can tell by how the media are
covering this
who they think won new york times
headline a fly lands out on mike pence's
head during the vp debate for two
minutes
the hill biden fundraise is off a fly on
pence's head cnn
fly lands on mike pence's heads during
debate vox the fly in mike pence's head
was the real winner of the 2020 vice
presidential debate
washington post an exclusive interview
with the fly from the debate
that joe biden tweeted out a picture of
himself with a fly swatter saying he
wanted to fundraise
first of all joe biden is more likely to
smack himself in the face with a fly
swatter than properly swat a fly at this
point in his geriatric life
how ridiculous was the media coverage of
this the media coverage was
ridiculous through and through they had
only a couple narratives coming out of
this one was kamala harris is a victim
and the other of course is that there
was a fly at the debate those were those
were the two narratives
so steve schmidt who is of course a a
former republican now he is a like
complete never trump
crazy person he said on msnbc
that the fly landing on mike pence was a
sign that he was satan
here was steve schmidt last night i mean
i don't think it's ever a good sign when
a fly lands on your
head for two minutes you know that's a
that's a sign all through history of sin
and historically biblically uh maybe
you wouldn't normally say this after you
wouldn't it's only safe to say this
sorry after midnight but
you know the a fly he who commands the
fly has always been seen historically
the mark of the devil
okay it didn't stop there obviously you
got andrea
mitchell andrea mitchell then went to
the mansplaining
mansplaining routine she says i asked a
man i know what he thought of the debate
he said the debate was over when she
said mr vice president you are
interrupting me
then uh she needs to hang out with like
men who exist not ones that exist in her
imagination
you know like men who are biologically
men because that's crazy
okay the minute she said you're
interrupting me susan page interrupted
her we showed you the clip
susan page interrupted her and then
trump and then pence jumped in
and then she's like well she said stop
interrupting me to a man that was
standing up for women everywhere
women power this was the talking point
in the media as soon as you are
relegated
to saying that she was the victim of
pence's wild sexism
yeah good luck with that van jones on
cnn did the
did the same thing he suggested that
pence was the quote unquote mansplainer
in chief just because he is a man and he
is explaining things does not mean he is
mansplaining things
he was not talking down to kamal harris
it's a political debate yeah idiots
it's a political debate here is van
jones trying to try out this tired
talking point
she was not overly assertive throughout
this entire debate
was a man mansplainer in
i understand that but okay and and then
you get george stephanopoulos the
keebler elf
suggesting there was tons of man
explaining last night just endless
endless mansplaining
last night from george stephanopo
stephanopoulos objective news anchor
because obviously mike pence is a former
television commentator does have a very
calm demeanor but i think a lot of
people were noticing some mansplaining
going on tonight
okay then stop there nicole wallace on
msnbc she did the same thing
but she didn't just go there she got
full-on sexist against mike pence
okay so you're you're allowed to you're
not allowed to interrupt camel harris
under any circumstances ever ever ever
if you do you're sexist
stop it you're a bad person cut it out
okay but but
nicole wallace literally called mike
pence flaccid
and limp in the debate oh is she making
a
a pun about his penis yes of course she
is because you're allowed to say
whatever you want about men in our
society but
if you interrupt a woman if you so much
as interrupted woman during a debate
it's because
you hate women you see you hate them
hate them
she said the only people they have in
their coalition after last week's barn
burner from trump were the grievance
voters
this will not land well with them
and then she suggested that perhaps she
actually went on to suggest nicole
wallace
that perhaps mike pence was feeling
under the weather right she started
talking about the fact that his eyes
looked a little pink so maybe he has
covered
so that's her narrative now we're going
to speculate about mike pence's health
maybe he has coveted who the hell knows
maybe he does
mark ruffalo signed in as well to uh to
join in the fun
the idiot actor a man with uh fewer than
ten braintel scrubbed together
he tweeted out just going over it all in
my head the way mike pence constantly
interrupted and spoke over kamal harris
was the prime example of white
male supremacy and it's common dismissal
and disrespect for black women
i i have a question let's say that the
sexes
had been reversed and let's say that
kamala harris had been the one who
mildly interrupted mike pence and pence
had said you're interrupting me you're
interrupting me stop interrupting me
then they would claim that he was being
defensive and aggressive with kamala
harris
there is in fact a double standard but
the double standard is applied against
men and not against women in these
circumstances that is perfectly obvious
it's been obvious from the media
coverage
since before the debate this is
ridiculous
essie cup on cnn she did the same thing
she said that uh she blasted mike pence
she said his debate was infuriating he
made
her skin crawl skin crawl you see
i know mike pence i've met mike pence
i've interviewed mike pence and at one
time i found him very impressive
tonight he made my skin crawl
uh and i think showed that you can uh
be insulting without using insults um
you know the the constant interruptions
the mansplaining
the condescending to both of the women
on that stage tonight and and the not
answering questions the
gaslighting i found infuriating okay th
this is just i'm sorry it's very silly
it is very obvious pence one the media's
coverage proves that pence won
okay so now here's the question can this
turn into momentum can this turn into
momentum and the answer is
maybe but trump has to get out of his
own way once again this campaign is not
about mike pence if pence were the
presidential candidate i think the
republican ticket would now be ahead in
the polls
donald trump needs to get out of his own
way he needs
to do the same defense of his policies
that pence did
he can do it in trumpian fashion he can
but he needs to actively defend his own
policies
rather than fulminating over whatever he
saw on the tvs today
and if that happens maybe this thing
turns around if it doesn't then the
problems will continue for the trump
campaign but again well i think the
takeaway last night is that trump's
policies are excellent how do you know
because mike pence was able to win going
away win in a walk
against kamala harris simply by saying
the policies out loud and pointing out
that democrats have never had to answer
a single difficult question
about their own policies and in fact
refuse to answer their own policies
right now
if you listen to kamala harris last
night democrats are the parties of
anti-green new deal
low taxes and pro fracking as as uh
elizabeth brooding an actual socialist
writing for the washington post said
it seems like if this is the new
democratic party they left the left
completely behind of course it isn't
they're lying
but just demonstrates how much they have
to lie in order to convince the american
people they are not who they actually
are
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick shien the
show is edited by adam syavets
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton